across a dozen different TV shows 13
movies and almost 60 years hundreds of
actors have explored the final frontier
on Star trk quite a few have since
passed on These Are the Voyages of the
ones you may not
know before Captain James T Kirk took
the center seat on the Enterprise she
was commanded by Captain Christopher
Pike Jeffrey Hunter played Captain Pike
in the original Star Trek pilot the cage
but when NBC asked for a second pilot
Hunter refused to return multiple
accounts by other key Star Trek
Personnel suggest that his wife at the
time played a major role in his decision
which led Star Trek Creator Gene
Roddenberry to cast William Shatner as
the newly rechristened Captain Kirk
what's
that I didn't say there's anything wrong
with me Pike remained part of tre cannon
with Roden Barry incorporating footage
from the cage into a two-part episode
called the managerie as for Hunter his
modestly successful career had already
included roles in the groundbreaking
Western the Searchers and the biblical
epic king of kings in which he played
Jesus Christ he continued to work in
film films and TV after track but
suffered a brain hemorrhage on May 26th
1969 at his home in vanise California
and fell down some stairs fracturing his
skull the 42-year-old Hunter died the
next morning on May 27th
1969 while the Klingons and romulans
were recurring enemies on the original
Star Trek only one individual villain
appeared on the show more than once
hardcourt Fenton Harry mud Interstellar
conman twice portrayed by character
actor Roger C carmell in his early 30s
when he played mud Carmel had already
racked up a sizable amount of credits on
Broadway TV and in film when he got the
nod he voiced the character once more
for mud's passion a 1973 episode of Star
Trek the Animated Series Carmel died at
age 54 on November 11th 1986 with an
official cause of death of hypertropic
cardiomyopathy a disease of the heart
muscles in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of KH
Admiral James T Kirk finally confronts a
secret from his past namely that he has
a grown son named David from a previous
relationship with Dr Carol Marcus head
of The Genesis Project although father
and son are initially not on good terms
they reconcile by the end of the film
only for David to meet his death at the
hands of the Klingons in Star Trek 3 The
Search for Spock David was played by
Meritt butrick a Florida native who
amassed a steady amount of work between
1981 in 1989 mostly on TV that included
a regular role as Johnny slash on Square
pegs and a guest appearance on the Star
Trek the Next Generation season 1
episode symbiosis as an alien named ton
unfortunately his career was cut short
when he died at age 29 due to
complications from Aids on March 17th
1989 after the regular cast there may
have been no Star Trek to actor more
closely associated with the show than
Mark Leonard the actor first appeared in
the classic season 1 episode balance of
Terror as the commander of a Romulan
vessel playing a deadly cat and mouse
game with the Enterprise he returned in
season 2 as cak the aranged father of Mr
Spock in the episode journey to bable Mr
spark will conduct you I prefer another
guide
captain
Leonard voiced cak for the yesteryear
episode of Star Trek the animated series
and showed up as a Klingon commander in
1979's Star Trek the motion picture
making him the only actor to play a
member of the three major Trek alien
races he dawned the ears again as cak
for three feature films also reprising
the character in The cak and unification
part 1 episodes of Star Trek the Next
Generation cak was clearly Leonard's
most famous role but his journeyman
career also included extensive work on
the stage as well as guest spots on the
incredible hole Hawaii 5 Mission
Impossible and a recurring role as
General erko on the short-lived 1974
planet of the ape series leoner died on
November 22nd 1996 at the age of 72 from
cancer born in Bombay in 1948 persus
kambada became in 1965 just the third
Indian woman in history to compete in
the Miss Universe Pageant her work as a
model led to small roles in a handful of
Bollywood and British pictures before
she was picked to play Lieutenant iyah
the bald Delta Navigator of the ENT
prise Kata agreed to shave her head for
the role which was initially developed
in 1977 for the Star Trek phase 2 TV
series before that was abandoned in
favor of Star Trek the motion picture in
1979 her appearance in Star Trek led to
more roles in films like Nighthawks and
megga force and although she was a
contender for the title role in the
James Bond Thriller octopusy the part
went to mod Adams guest spots on shows
like mcgyver and Lois and Clark The New
Adventures of Superman followed plagued
since 1980 by health problems Kata
succumbed to a mass heart attack in
Mumbai on August 18th 1998 at the age of
49 born in Georgia in 1920 DeForest
Kelly pursued acting after serving in
World War II and landed his first role
in the 1946 film fear in the night a
consistent stream of film stage and TV
gigs followed with his role as Morgan IR
in 1957's gunfight at the OK Corral
getting him cast mostly As villains for
the 9 years that followed Spock you
haven't changed a bit you're just as
warm and sociable as ever although
though he was at one point considered
for the role of Mr Spock Kelly appeared
in neither of the show's two pilots
series Creator Jee Roddenberry offered
him the role of the chief medical
officer renamed McCoy prior to the
beginning of production on season 1 and
Kelly went on to appear in all but three
episodes during the show's three-year 79
episode run he also voiced McCoy and
Star Trek the Animated Series like many
to cast members Kelly hit a dry spell in
the 1970s until he got the call for Star
Trek the motion picture that led to five
subsequent films and a brief cameo in
the Premier episode of Star Trek the
Next Generation McCoy's mix of sarcasm
and compassion and his chemistry with
William Shatner and Leonard nemoy made
him an indispensable part of Star Trek
Kelly died of stomach cancer at the age
of 79 on June 11th
1999 Canadian actor John kakos made Star
Trek history as core the Show's first
major klling on adversary in the
original series season 1 episode erand
of
Mercy you do not like to be
pushed
very good according to Mark kushman's
These Are the Voyages kakos was supposed
to play core again in season 2's the
trouble with triples and season 3's day
of the dove but was unavailable both
times he along with the actors who did
play the main Kling on antagonists on
those segments later appeared on Star
Trek Deep Space 9 reprising core in the
episode Blood Oath in addition to two
more episodes of DS9 kass's other sci-fi
credentials include the role of count
balar on the original 1978 Battle Star
Galactica and voicing apocalypse on
X-Men the Animated Series in the mid
1990s before his death at age 71 on
March 6th 200000 kakos had compiled
nearly 100 screen credits but he'll
always be the first Kling on no one
loved the Enterprise more than chief
engineer Montgomery Scott and James
duan's portrayal of The Miracle Worker
is a Cornerstone of the Star Trek
universe I can't change the laws of
physics I got to have 30 minutes
according to inside Star Trek the real
story Creator Gene rotenberry almost
fired him after his first episode but do
and Scotty became an integral part of
all three seasons of the original series
The Animated Series and seven of the
feature films as well as a sixth season
episode of Star Trek the Next Generation
a veteran of World War I the Canadian
born Duan saw combat and was wounded
during the D-Day invasion of Normandy he
already had a vast Trove of TV and radio
work under his belt when he boarded the
Enterprise and was quite Adept at
voiceover work he often voiced aliens
computers and other non-h humanoids on
the original series he also performed
multiple roles on the Animated Series
while work outside of Star Trek dried up
in his later years he remained
enormously popular at Star Trek
conventions until 2004 when Alzheimer's
disease and Parkinson's disease forced
him out of the spotlight he died in 2005
and some of his ashes made it into space
in 2008 and
2012 Jane Wyatt's career in film and TV
stretched from 1934 to 1992 but she is
probably best remembered for two roles
homemaker Margaret Anderson for six
seasons and some 200 plus episodes of
the sitcom Father Knows Best and Amanda
Grayson the human mother of the
Enterprises first officer Mr Spock she
first played Amanda on the original
series season 2 episode journey to Babel
which movingly explored the backstory of
Spock and a strained relationship with
his father cak Wyatt reprised the role
in 1986's Star Trek 4 the Voyage Home
she won three Emmys for Father Knows
Best and worked consistently for the
rest of her life even scoring a
recurring role on sa elsewhere from 1985
to 1987 Wyatt passed away at age 96 in
October
2006 known as the first lady of Star
Trek magel Barrett met then married Tre
Creator Jee Roddenberry in 1961 and at
some point the two began an affair
Roddenberry cast Barrett as number one
in the first Trek pilot the cage but was
asked to remove the character for the
subsequent series nevertheless the
series Creator snuck her back on in the
role of Nurse Christine Chapel a move
that according to the book inside Star
Trek the real story almost got the both
both of them fired by Desi L Studios
head Lucille Ball Roddenberry and
Barrett stuck around however and Barrett
who married Roddenberry in 1969 played
Chapel in 25 original series episodes as
well as the animated series and two of
the feature films she later played luxan
Troy mother of ship's counselor di Troy
on multiple episodes of The Next
Generation in Deep Space 9 she also
provided the voice of the ship's
computer in every Star Trek series
through Voyager even making a couple
appearances on Enterprise as well as the
2009 Reboot film for she completed her
work shortly before her death and
authorization code 95 wictor wictor 2
authorization not
recognized a regular on the convention
circuit she remained devoted to Star
Trek and Jee Roddenberry who died in
1991 until her own death from leukemia
in 2008 at the age of
76 K Nunan Singh is generally considered
one of the greatest villains if not the
greatest in tre
[Music]
history one of a group of genetically
enhanced humans who tried to conquer
Earth in the late 20th century he and
his followers put themselves in
suspended animation aboard an
Interstellar vessel and slept for
centuries waking up and trying to take
over the Enterprise in the classic
episode space seed KH returned 15 years
later in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of KH out
for revenge against Captain Kirk for the
death of Khan's wife KH was played both
times by the Mexican actor Ricardo
Montalban who also starred as Mr work in
the hit 1970s TV series Fantasy Island
and also played the key role of circus
owner Armando in two of the Planet of
the Apes movies from earlier that decade
a star in Mexico since the 1940s he kept
working into his 80s Landing late roles
in the Spy Kid series Montalban also
co-founded The Nosotros Foundation to
advocate for the better portrayal of
Latinos in the entertainment industry he
died in 2009 at age 88 from heart
failure born in Newark New Jersey
William Campbell had the distinction of
playing two of the best known villains
on the original Trek series in season 1
he played train the super powered being
known as The Squire of gothis who turns
out to be a spoiled child using the
Enterprise and its crew as literal play
things in season 2 he played Captain
koloth the slippery klling on commander
who clashes with Kirk in the trouble
with tribles a role he reprised for the
Blood Oath episode of Deep Space 9 among
Campbell's other credits were Elvis
Presley's screen debut 1956's Love Me
Tender 1963's Dementia 13 which was
Francis Ford cop's first directorial
effort and the 1964 psychological
Thriller Hush Hush sweet Charlotte with
Betty DAV and Olivia deand he passed
away in 2011 at age
87 born in Syria Michael andara was
often cast as Native American Latino and
Middle Eastern characters in films and
TV shows before playing the brutal yet
reasonable Commander Kang on the season
3 original series episode day of the
dove he was best known for playing the
legendary Native American coaches on the
TV series broken narrow fans will also
remember him for several appearances on
I Dream of Genie opposite Barbara Eden
to whom he was also married for 16 years
and as the voice of Mr Freeze on Batman
the Animated Series he got to reprise
the role of Kang in the DS9 episode
Blood Oath and in the Voyager episode
flashback and Sara died in 2013 at the
age of
91 cast by Gene Roddenberry in the role
for the original Star Trek pilot the
cage Leonard nemoy Spock was the only
character that survived a complete cast
overhaul for the series even though NBC
was against his inclusion the cool
logical half-human Spock became the
show's most popular character nemoy also
snagged two Emmy nominations for the
role Nemo's place in pop culture history
had long been secured when he passed
away at age 83 in 2015 from chronic
obstructive pulmonary disease or COPD in
addition to his extensive acting and
directing credits which included helming
two of the Star Trek feature films nemoy
was a longtime advocate for the Arts a
devote to science and an activist for
Jewish causes he even had an asteroid
named after him the cosmic ballet goes
on Grace Lee Whitney appeared as yman
Janice Rand in just Eight Episodes of
Star Trek the Original Series but Rand
remains an enduring character from the
show's early days halfway through the
first season Whitney was released from
her contract reasons given for her exit
include budget cuts and a desire on the
Network's part to let Kirk pursue women
on the show without having Rand around
she later alleged that a sexual assault
by an unnamed Studio executive may have
contributed as well Whitney did return
for brief appearances in Four Star Trek
films and remained popular on the
convention circuit she had a long screen
and singing career before Trek and
continued to work afterwards although
she dedicated much of her later years as
a survivor of substance and alcohol
abuse to helping others with their
recovery she died from natural causes on
May 1st 2015 at the age of
85 during his brief 27 years of life
Russian born Anton Yelchin still managed
to make an impact on audiences around
the world yelin played IGN pavle check
off in JJ Abrams 2009 reboot of Star
Trek 2013's Star Trek Into Darkness and
2016's Star Trek Beyond which was
released after his death producers
announced that the role would not be
recast after yelchin's death in an
accident on June 19th 2016 yelin first
made an impression in 2002 in the TV
miniseries taken and went on to star in
films such as Alpha Dog Terminator
Salvation Lake crazy fright night and
Green Room a documentary about his life
love and TOA premiered at the 2019
Sundance Film Festival Renee abano began
his career in the theater and landed
three Broadway plays during the 1968 to
1969 season earning a Tony Award for the
third Coco his first big film
breakthrough was as father Mahi in
Robert alman's 1970 film Mash a burino
appeared in several more Altman films as
well as dozens of other features and TV
shows over his lengthy career he had a
brief role that was cut out of the
theatrical release of 1991's Star Trek 6
the Undiscovered Country but his lasting
contribution to the franchise was on
Deep Space 9 where he played the title
station's shape-shifting head of
security Odo the conflicted character
who helped the Federation battle his own
race the founders was a fan favorite
ainoa died of lung cancer in 2019 at age
79 best known for playing Tom Robinson
in the 1962 film adaptation of tequilla
Mockingbird Rock Peters would go on to
appear in several Star Trek projects he
appeared as Admiral cartright in both
Star Trek 4 the Voyage Home and Star
Trek 6 the Undiscovered Country where it
was revealed that he had betrayed the
Federation and allied with a group of
dissident Klingons to sabotage peace
talks Peters would return to the
franchise in 1996 in a very role playing
Joseph Cisco father of Captain Benjamin
Cisco on six episodes of Deep Space 9
you know Dad you could come and visit us
at the station once in a while don't
start that again Earth's my home it's
where I belong Peters also starred in a
number of other films including soilent
green and porgi and Bess a musical in
which he also starred on Broadway sci-fi
fans may also recognize him as the voice
of Darth Vader in the Star Wars radio
dramas where he stood in for James Earl
Jones Peters died from pancreatic canc
answer answer in 2005 at the age of
78 in the Deep Space 9 episode family
business comedian Andrea Martin was cast
to play the fingy quark and rah's mother
ishka but once she became a recurring
character CES Adams was brought in to
fill the role in four additional
episodes Adams was actually younger than
the actors who played her sons leaving
it to the series impressive makeup
effects to make her appear older the
daughter of get smart star da Adams
sesily didn't act as much as her dad did
only taking small roles in various other
shows for most of her career Adams was
actually a casting director and worked
on Classics like that 70 show and Third
Rock From the Sun in 2004 Adams passed
away from lung cancer at the young age
of just
46 television audiences of the 1960s
knew Robert Lancing well he could be
seen on Wagon Train The Twilight Zone
and gunm smoke among countless other
shows in the 1980s he played control the
mysterious supervisor in the hit action
series The Equalizer and Lieutenant Jack
Curtis in the short-lived sci-fi
Adventure Show Automan during his Heyday
Lancing was brought into to play Gary 7
in the classic Star Trek episode
assignment Earth the original idea was
for the episode to serve as a backdoor
pilot for a spin-off with Lancing and
fellow guest star Terry gar but it never
took off seven was a human whose
ancestors had been abducted by a
mysterious alien race tasked with
watching over the Affairs of mankind in
the 20th century Lancing passed away in
1994 and his legacy lives on the story
of Gary s's people and their mission was
continued in season 2 of peard
there are few mythological figures in
Star Trek lore that conjure up as much
mystique and reference as the Klingon
Warrior KES in an episode of the
original Star Trek he said to be the
founder of the Klingon Empire in Star
Trek the Next Generation his Legend has
grown to The Greatest Warrior in Klingon
history an almost Christlike figure who
was prophesied to return and Lead his
people to New Glory when he did
resurrected by genetic engineering in
the episode rightful Heir he was played
by Kevin Conway science fiction fans
know Conway's voice well he he provided
the intro and outro narration for the
1995 reboot of the outer limits he also
had a lengthy career on the big screen
mostly playing supporting roles in
movies like slaughterhouse 5 Jennifer 8
and the quick and the dead he had
countless credits on TV and in the late
2000s he joined the goodwi in a
recurring role as Jonas Stern his final
on-screen role he died in 2020 Richard
herd had roles in several iconic SciFi
franchises he played the visitors
Supreme Commander in the cult classic V
in 1983 and its followup V the final
battle he also turned up in a recurring
role in sequest dsv as well as a pair of
episodes of Quantum Leap trekkies will
no doubt remember him as Admiral Owen
Paris the father of Star Trek Voyager
Helmsman Tom Paris who becomes a present
in the later seasons of the show as the
ship got closer to home Admiral Paris
wasn't actually herd's only Star Trek
role in the Next Generation episode
Birthright he also portrayed the leader
of a group of Klingons who had been
taken captive by romulans and made a
home on a remote Colony with their
former adversaries out sight of Trek
audiences probably remember him best
from Seinfeld as Mr Wilhelm George
castan's boss when he worked for the New
York Yankees
wilh my name is Tanya herd died from
complications from cancer in 2020 at the
age of
87 W Morgan Shepard played four major
characters across multiple Star Trek
shows and films with the rare
distinction of playing different
characters in the original Star Trek
timeline and the JJ Abrams reboots his
first role came in 1988 when he played
Federation scientist Ira graves in the
Next Generation episode The skitso Man
in which he steals data's body to extend
his lifespan he then moved to the films
playing the Kling on commandant at the
rur peny penal colony in Star Trek 6 the
Undiscovered Country then returning to
TV in the Star Trek Voyager episode
Bliss in 2009 Shephard came back to Trek
to portray the Vulcan administrator who
berates a young Mr Spock sci-fi fans
will also remember his role in the
Doctor Who episode The Impossible
Astronaut where he plays an older
version of of Canton Delaware III with
his younger self played by his real life
son Mark Shepard Mark announced the
passing of his father in 2019 at the age
of
86 Spock's a logical Vulcan who isues
emotion so fans were as surprised as the
rest of the crew to be introduced to his
betrothed a Vulcan named topring she was
played by Arlene Martell in the now
iconic episode amuk Time known for its
famous fight music the episode pit Spock
and Kirk against each other in a death
match before Star Trek Martell had
appeared in a pair of episodes of The
Twilight Zone as well as small parts in
I Dream of Genie and the Man from Uncle
she continued acting on television
through the 70s and ' 80s but was
largely retired by the 2000s topring has
been recast for 2022 Star Trek strange
new worlds where she is played by Gia
Sandu but Martell will long be
remembered as the first in the role in
2014 she suffered a heart attack that
would lead to her death shortly
thereafter at the age of
78 Star Trek Deep Space 9 was markedly
different from its predecessors with a
decidedly religious angle to its story
something that started St Trek had
almost entirely Shi away from to that
point embodying this religious element
were the bajorans whose spiritual leader
was Kai opaka played by Camille saviola
sava's filmography is littered with
guest roles in some of TV's biggest hits
La law NYPD Blue friends ER Judging Amy
and Entourage just to name a few she
only appeared in four episodes of Deep
Space 9 but saviola would be best
remembered for her recurring role as
kopaka she was pivotal early in the
series helping guide Comm Cisco into his
role as the Boran Emissary to the
prophets savola died of heart failure in
2021 at age
71 Star Trek 6 the Undiscovered Country
featured film veteran David Warner is
cling on Chancellor gorin whose death
kicks off the film's riveting story but
it's actually not the first role he
played in the franchise nor would it be
the last a few years earlier Warner
played St John Talbot in Star Trek 5 the
final frontier he also returned and Star
Trek the Next Generation in the classic
two-parter chain of command where he
played a brutal Kardashian interrogator
who tortures Captain Bard Shall We Begin
[Music]
Again how many lights are there Beyond
Star Trek Warner was famous for roles in
Titanic and the omen and had key roles
in cult classics like Time Bandits and
Tron while also doing some well-regarded
voiceover work an Emmy Award winner for
his role in the 1981 miniseries Masada
Warner died in July 2022 at age 80 from
a cancer related
illness one of the most unexpected
villains on Deep Space 9 was was Kai win
who took the role of bour spiritual
leader after the death of opaka in
season 2 she quickly became a political
rival for Captain Cisco and her scheming
machinations and hunger for power made
her a threat to peace playing her was
Louise Fletcher one of the most highly
respected Hollywood actors ever to earn
a recurring role in the franchise in
1975 Fletcher starred as the similarly
Sinister nurse ratchet opposite Jack
Nicholson in one Fu Over the Cuckoo's
Nest a role that earned her an Academy
Award after a nearly 60-year career
Fletcher died peace peacefully at her
home in September of 2022 at the age of
88 Kirsty Ali is no doubt best known for
her role as Rebecca how on Cheers she
followed that up with her own series
Veronica's Closet in 1997 and led
several other films and shows but years
before her television Fame allly played
the iconic role of the Vulcan lieutenant
savic in Star Trek 2 the Wrath of KH in
the film she's the Protege of Mr Spock
they're notable for being the first
characters to ever speak the Vulcan
language on screen allly turned down an
offer to return and start Trek 3 and was
replaced by Robin Curtis nearly a decade
later when her cheers co-star Kelsey
Grammar guest starred in an episode of
The Next Generation it was originally
planned for Ally to reprise her role but
according to Star trek.com scheduling
conflicts quashed her appearance still
Ali's mark on the franchise is a big one
and the Tre Community felt a major loss
when she passed away from colon cancer
in December 2022 at age
71 in season 2 of Star Trek Bard the
former Enterprise Captain finds himself
squaring off with an old foe the Bor
Queen first seen in Star Trek first
Contact but it's not quite the same bore
Queen instead of original actress Alice
C it was Annie woring under the Borg
makeup for That season woring was
already a Star Trek Alum having guest
started an episode of Star Trek
Enterprise all the way back in 2002 her
very first credited role from there
woring appeared all over television with
roles in Charmed Boston Legal and
Supernatural before landing a recurring
role in 24 in 2009 she was the voice of
Tess in the wildly popular video game
The Last of us while fans of The Vampire
Diaries will remember her from her role
as Lily she appeared to be on the ascent
securing regular roles in the Marvel
series runaways and Bosch sadly woring
died from cancer in early 2023 at just
45 her Star Trek roles were both the
first and final onscreen appearances of
her career when the original Star Trek
debuted in 1966 it had a black woman on
the bridge and a rare display of racial
diversity on Prime Time television
Nichelle Nichols played Communications
officer Aura and quickly became a trail
blazing icon for both women's rights and
Racial equality africanamerican saw the
show and went what you know like we're
on TV she's also credited for half of
the first interracial kiss on television
with Siri star William Shatner before
Trek Nichols played a role in a Gene
Roddenberry written episode of The
Lieutenant all about racial intolerance
but the episode proved too controversial
for TV and never aired making her role
as a hura her first credited role on
television
Nichols who helped Inspire scores of
young women famously quit Star Trek only
to be talked into returning to the
series by Martin Luther King Jr himself
Nicholls became the face of women in
science and even became a recruiter for
NASA in the 1970s while she never won
any major awards for her performance as
Aura she was nominated for a Daytime
Emmy in 2017 for a four episode run on
The Young and the Restless and received
a Lifetime Achievement Award from The
Academy of Science Fiction horror and
fantasy films Nicholls died at the age
of 89 in 2022 leaving behind a legacy of
Grace and strength for future
Generations Gary Graham played the
Vulcan Ambassador soal in Star Trek
Enterprise early on in the series soval
is something of an antagonist to Scott
Bakula's Captain Archer with his belief
that humans are yet ready to launch the
nx-01 Enterprise and joined the larger
Interstellar Community by the 2001
premiere of Enterprise Graham was
already well known to sci-fi audiences
soal wasn't even his first role in Star
Trek in 1995 he guest starred in the
Star Trek Voyager episode cold fire he
also starred in the 1989 cult series
Alien Nation Graham took over the James
con role from the film version of Nation
playing police officer Matthew Sykes he
starred in the show's only season and
returned for five subsequent made for TV
movies it was the only time he led his
own show but it certainly wasn't his
only Sci-Fi cult classic the other being
the dystopian be movie classic robot
jocks a decade after Enterprise ended
Graham reprised his role as soal in the
fan film Star Trek Prelude to axanar
he'd planned to return for a fulllength
feature version but the project became
the target of a multi-million doll
copyright lawsuit and Graham left the
production in 2020 he passed away on
January 22nd 2024 survived by his wife
Becky and daughter
Haley